-Welcome to "The Tonight Show,"
everybody.
Let's get to the news
and jokes.
Well, guys, after two days
of controversy,
today President Trump finally
did the right thing
and forcefully rejected
white supremacy.
Take a look.
[ Tone ]
[ Laughter ]
I'm --
-I'm kidding.
He hasn't done that at all.
And as a result, Republicans
are distancing themselves
from the president.
-The president's debate
performance has sparked
a torrent of criticism
that even his most ardent allies
have struggled to contain.
And Republicans on Capitol Hill
are now distancing themselves
from the president
after he failed to disavow
a far-right fascist group.
-There's been six months
of a pandemic
and now the Republicans
are distancing?
[ Laughter ]
Yup, they're really trying to
distance themselves
from Trump's
white supremacy issue.
In fact, today Mitch McConnell
brought a bill
to the Senate floor to bring
back the Source Awards.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, what?
[ Applause ]
That's right, Republicans said
this as the last straw.
Then tomorrow they'll be like,
"Oh, we found a bunch
more straws."
[ Laughter ]
Turns out all these
controversies are causing
the president's biggest
supporters
to experience "Trump fatigue."
I think it might be true.
Today when Trump called in
to "Fox & Friends,"
Steve Doocy was like,
"Ugh,
just let the machine get it."
[ Laughter ]
"We have to talk for 45 minutes,
and just so --
Yeah, what did say?"
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
How do you get away from Trump
though?
It's like dealing with a bear.
Do you run?
Do you act big?
Do you play dead?
No one knows.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Republicans are finally
stepping up to say it's not okay
to publicly support
white supremacy...more than
seven or eight times, tops.
Eight is -- eight is enough.
[ Laughter ]
Well, earlier today,
John Roberts from Fox News
tried to give the White House
a chance to clear things up
and denounce white supremacy,
but Press Secretary
Kayleigh McEnany
had a tough time with that.
Watch this.
-Just to clear it up this
morning, can you, naming it,
make a declarative statement
that you denounce --
that the president denounces it?
-I just did.
The president has denounced
this repeatedly.
-You read a bunch of quotes
from the past.
-The president was asked this.
You're making --
You're contriving a story.
-No I'm not.
-Yeah, Trump's like
some sort of mythical troll.
You got to ask the same question
three times before you
get the answer
you're looking for.
[ With accent ] "There's only
one way to reveal the answer --
say the question,
but in reverse."
[ Laughter ]
The only way their gonna condemn
white supremacy is
if you sneak it into Trump's
teleprompter the way you sneak
medicine into a dog food.
[ As Trump ]
"And then we're gonna --
I do not support white
supremacists.
Bring back football."
[ Laughter ]
After that exchange,
Roberts didn't hold back
how he was feeling.
This is real.
Take a look at this.
-And for all of you
on Twitter who are hammering me
for asking that question,
I don't care,
because it's a question
that needs to be asked
and clearly the president's
Republican colleagues
a mile away from here
are looking for an answer
for it, too.
So stop deflecting.
Stop blaming the media.
I'm tired of it.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Even Fox News is fed up
with Trump.
That's like HGTV telling
the Property Brothers
to take their tight jeans
and near beards and beat it.
[ Laughter ]
-Tariq: Near beards.
[ Applause ]
-I hope that becomes a thing,
man.
After Monday's tax bombshell,
Tuesday's debate debacle,
and Wednesday's
white supremacy disaster,
Trump seemed pretty down
at last night's rally.
[ "YMCA" plays ]
-♪ Young man ♪
♪ There's no need to feel down ♪
♪ Stay at the YMCA ♪
[ Laughter ]
-That's actual audio.
That's real -- yeah.
Yes, of course.
The classic "YMCA" dance.
Clapping, pointing, and drawing
a circle with you finger.
[ Laughter ]
One, two, three.
It's fun to stay --
♪ YMCA ♪
♪♪
♪ They got everything ♪
♪ Making boys to men ♪
♪ Everything that a man
could be ♪
♪♪
-Y...
Right after that dance,
white supremacists
forcefully rejected Trump.
[ Laughter ]
Here's a fun fact.
Trump is in so much debt
pretty soon he'll be staying
at the YMCA.
[ Laughter ]
After watching that, it's clear
that if the presidency
doesn't work out, neither will
"Dancing With the Stars."
♪♪
I'm just kidding.
That was a nice moment.
Trump was having fun.
The crowd was having fun.
The coronavirus
was having fun.
[ Laughter ]
You know what, forget
the next debate.
Let's just make it a dance-off
instead.
-♪ Young man ♪
♪ When you're short on dough ♪
♪ You can stay there ♪
-Good God.
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
That's such a good move.
[ Laughter ]
-Everyone is still
talking about the debates.
Oh, my God. Well, except
for Rudy Giuliani,
who is talking
about the "debat."
[ Laughter ]
Amazing, you can't even tweet
about the debate
without Trump interrupting you.
Trump might be --
Rudy might be right, 'cause
I don't think you can legally
call what happened a debate.
Not sure where Rudy was going
with this.
He's either got something to say
about the debate
or he's looking for
a D batteries.
But Giuliani --
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
We are still on the air.
That's the good news.
Actually, Giuliani quickly
noticed and followed that up
with a "Oops, my ba."
[ Laughter ]
My ba.
Was afraid of the last letter.
-Yeah, I got it.
[ Laughter ]
The guy is doing Trump's debate
prep, he can't spell debate.
That's like getting a text
from your surgeon that says,
"Can't wait for
your surjeree."
[ Laughter ]
Some more news from Washington.
It just came out
that the White House
and the CDC
have been clashing over
how to handle cruise lines
during the pandemic,
take a look.
-The CDC is extending its ban
on cruising from U.S. ports
through the end of this month.
Axios is reporting the CDC's
director wanted to extend
the order until February,
but Vice President Pence
overruled him.
Even the cruise ships know
it's a bad idea.
For a six-day trip they tell
you to pack for nine months.
[ Laughter ]
It'll be a while.
Yeah, the White House
overruled the CDC
on the current cruise ship ban,
which might explain
this new ad I saw.
-Are you ready to get out
of your apartment?
-Yes.
-Are you tired of your
same old pandemic routine?
-Oh, yeah.
-Then join us this November
for a Carnival Cruise.
[ Ship horn blows ]
-Wait, what?
-Dive into a pool filled with
kids swimming in diapers.
-Do I have to?
-Share a wet mic
at a karaoke lounge.
-Why?
-Dig in hands first
at our delicious buffet.
-Is this a trap?
-Carnival Cruise.
Just a few liability waivers
away from setting sail.
[ Ship horn blows ]
[ Imitates horn ]
[ Applause ]
Well, this isn't good.
The highest court in Ireland
just made a pretty shocking
ruling, listen to this.
-Ireland Supreme Court has
ruled that the bread served
at Subway restaurants can't
legally be defined as bread.
Subway's bread contains
five times
the qualifying limit of sugar.
-Man, all this time
I thought it was healthy
to eat a meatball parm
on 12 inches of honey bread.
[ Laughter ]
Why am I gaining weight?
After the ruling,
Subway was like, "Whew.
They didn't say anything
about the meat."
[ Laughter ]
It wasn't just bread.
The court also said,
"And by the way, stop calling
the guy making my sandwich
an 'artist.'"
[ Laughter ]
That wasn't true.
I made that up. That was a joke.
[ Laughter ]
Also, what's going on in Ireland
where that made it to their
highest court?
Our highest court is about
to argue over health care,
and Ireland's arguing
over sandwiches.
Can we live there?
[ Laughter ]
Then the justices are like,
[ Irish accent ]
"Next on the docket,
are Taco Bell's tacos
actually tacos?"
[ Laughter ]
That's one of my Irish accents,
but this --
This one, what I do, it's
the out-of-breath Irish accent.
Can you do an Irish accent?
-Sure.
-Do it.
Say "Taco Bell's aren't tacos."
-[ Irish accent ]
Taco Bell's aren't tacos!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's not Irish. I don't know
who you sound like,
but it's not Irish, but --
But now do it but run out
of breath, like...
-Okay. Uh, tacos...
[ Laughter ]
-I'm not a --
I'm not a dialect coach.
What am I -- what am I doing?
What am I doing?
I apologize. I apologize.
-Your Irish accent sounds
more Jamaican to me.
-[ Irish accent ]
"You never go to Jamaica...
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
...get jerk chicken."
[ Laughter ]
"They serve real
jerk chicken there!"
[ Laughter ]
-I love it. Ole.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I saw that a company
in the UK is testing a new way
to speed up paramedics'
response time.
This is cool, watch this.
-You could be looking at
the future
of emergency aid in this
simulation from the UK.
The paramedic with the
medical kit could
quickly respond to people
in a jet pack.
The suit has two mini engines on
each arm and one on the back.
[ Laughter ]
-Right now that guy is
currently hovering
over 50 Carnival Cruise ships.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's "quick."
All paramedics have to do
is get in the suit,
put on the gloves
and the helmet,
strap on the jet pack,
make sure he has enough fuel,
walk out to an open field,
take off
and slowly fly their way over.
And don't worry, there's
also a second paramedic
traveling behind for when
the first paramedic crashes.
[ Laughter ]
I'm just messing with you.
If there's one thing we know,
jet suits never fail.
-And it starts right now.
-Oh! Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-Classic. Pulling out
the classic, man.